bismillah al hamdulillah Salaam alaikum
peace be unto you welcome to another
episode of the Dean show my name is in
Dean I'm your host Eddie and we're here
talking about serious issues we're here
talking about things that are very
important we're talking about something
also that's very cool I think it's very
cool to be a Muslim is very cool to be
practicing Islam and knowing what your
purpose in life is knowing where you're
going when you die having some direction
and who best to give direction and the
one who created you why take direction
for anybody else why not take it from
the one who took care of you when you
and your mother's womb the one who's
running this whole universe and he's in
control of everything not why not take
direction from him we're going to talk
to one brother who's are just a cool cat
this brother is not a rapper he's not an
actor he's a Muslim and he's doing
something cool we'll be talking to our
brother the cool brother Oh mark Carter
here on the Dean show so you don't want
to go nowhere we'll be right back love
there's only one muhammad is his mess
love love love love
ah ha there's only one but Jesus was his
messenger Allah know why did that maybe
it maybe it's just to break the ice
assalamu alaikum brother o alaikum Salam
told off Omar Carter thanks for having
me on the DS show thank you my seating
here it's a pleasure to help I'm glad
you're here with us we've known each
other for a bit of a long time it's
benoa and I've been having you on my
mind that's good so when I introduced
when i made the deduction to the show I
said you're not a actor you're not a
rock star movie star hiphop phenomena
but you're a Muslim and I talked about
how cool it is to be a Muslim and I
wanted to bring that up because nowadays
you got to be sitting down with one of
these individuals the fifty cents in the
two parks for people to think that is
cool but I think it's cool to talk to
our brothers for us brothers to talk and
to talk about something that's cooler
than all that Islam and we want the
people to hear this story because you
weren't always Muslim and you weren't
always doing the coolest thing in the
world Islam you were doing something
else it's true tell us a little bit
about yourself what you do and some of
the history of what you used to live
before and then we'll come up to how and
where you are now well as you already
know I grew up in Jamaica moved to the
US when I was about 12 years old my
father was what people would say a
clergy member in the church yeah my
mother was also a clergy member we were
we all we grew up in the church
basically yeah if I remember Sunday
mornings I would cry saying i don't i
don't feel well i'm sick i don't want to
go to church today and my mother would
say come to church will pray for you so
I'll throughout my life I've had that a
you know i would say church upbringing i
was i grew up in the church and moved to
the united states when I was about 12
years old same process continued I was
still going to church my mother was
actively involved in the church my
father was also actively involved
the church and throughout that time you
know we would we would always go to
church pray but there was always
something in the back of my mind
wondering is there something beyond all
of this that I'm you know that you know
you go to church every Sunday and then
monday through saturday you pretty much
returned to the things that people do so
search was just a component or we would
say God was just one part he was maybe
we would go to church on Sunday and then
maybe monday we go and we do it whatever
else we we would normally do and he at
points and during the week we would uh
think about God we would pray before we
eat but there was still something that I
felt that I I was just missing then I
you know and for years it bothered you
know I researched I read did a lot of
reading and I just felt very
uncomfortable now for some people it's
okay you know to go to church and then
every Sunday may be involved in a youth
group or visit the sick people those are
all the things but at the end of the day
when you go home and you're going to bed
laying on the pillow thinking okay so
that this was the end of my day and that
was the point where I felt that is there
something else to this life so as I
continued when hours when i was around
19 I mean I stopped going to church and
I was about 14 yeah and at 19 I just I
did a lot of reading because for some
reason the question become more and more
embedded in my mind why are you here
there has to be more to life than just
what you see here and at that point I
started studying and I studied our
Buddhism Taoism all the isms you can
think of and somehow i came across a
book i had a friend of mine he would
always laugh at me said you know all
this thing's all these things you're
reading you could find it in islam but i
thought Islam was this weird religion
you know people wearing hats on their
heads long beard and
men wearing dresses and I you know it
was just something that you know it's
okay you know I don't have any problems
with these people but it's not something
that I wanted to do I wasn't attracted
to it and you know this this friend of
mine is we're still friends today he he
he was very patient with me he would
give me books to read he would check in
on me we would have a lot of
conversations out of going back and
forth and you know slowly but surely I
started discovering his farm you don't
by the way you mentioned heads and
dresses and all these other things but
you don't have any hats or dresses on
you and you're a Muslim nine you look
very sharp mashallah well that's the
beauty of Islam being a Muslim is of
course they're there people who they
were what what's called a thobe and the
kufi and that's that's true that's
traditionally something that people do
in their country it's also what we would
say it's a part of the Sunnah because
the Prophet may peace and blessings be
upon him he wore those things yeah and
some people feel that it brings them
closer to Islam it brings them closer to
the Prophet it shows love for the
Prophet there's absolutely nothing wrong
with that wearing those clothes but on
the other hand Islam is also a religion
that takes into account that there are
different people from different areas
with different colors different sizes
different shapes and the one thing that
brings us together is the love of Allah
the oneness of God the belief that there
is no god but allah and that muhammad is
his messenger and that islam is a
religion that promotes tolerance yeah so
so that's an interesting point yet
because uh Islam I mean you if you want
to dress modestly if you want to imitate
a lot of the prophets the last and final
messenger the best person to emulate
which is it's actually not a address
some people would say from the outside
what do these people were in dresses now
this is something just a modest way of
dressing dressing like the prophets
dress and if you look at the Muslims
today you this is how Jesus or any of
the prophets they used to dress and that
not in a net modest way the way a humble
way isn't that true that's right yeah so
let's talk about cool
because we kind of got this thing mixed
up we think you know that being cool is
you know getting some champagne and
going to the nightclub and riding around
in a limo and trying to be with these
superstars that you see on the TV but
what was your we know that's not cool
what was your definition of cool before
what were some of the cool things quote
on quote that you were doing before
Islam what did you consider cool what
did you find motivating you back then
well and for most people say I would say
it's the same its money money ah money
was a great motivator yeah I i loved the
money and with the money came a lot of
things you had a had a lot of i had nice
cars i had a lot of nice women i was
running around with but at the end of
the day it always came back to the
question why are you here are you happy
with what you have d you know you have
all this money you have a nice car you
have pretty girlfriends but at the end
of the day there's there was something
knocking in the bottom you know behind
the scenes in my soul the soul huh we're
where is all this going to take you
what's going to happen 20 years from now
that question always was always coming
back to me and I it was just you know I
thought getting a nicer car getting
another girlfriend or just having more
things would fill that void but the
thing I found out was that the more that
I acquired these things the more that I
wanted and that void wasn't being filled
because it's it's a void that cannot be
filled cannot be satiated with material
things so you mentioned Buddhism you
mentioned some other isms being brought
into a family of you know people who you
mentioned one time that you actually you
consider yourself like a bible thumper
oh yeah you got to that stage so you had
some knowledge right so let's briefly
talk about all these other isms before
you came to the cool way of life well
with with Christianity I mean I was
involved i got baptized when i was nine
years old yeah
and you know I was I was heavily
involved in the church I had a Bible I
was quoting verses from the Bible you
know Psalms 23 or Psalms 91 all these
things and more these verses Psalms
night was in these verses well Psalms is
basically what Muslims today called
izibor parts of it where David Dawood la
la meeeeee he he was inspired by our
Creator yeah and he he would he was
revealed the book was revealed to him
yeah so that's the equivalent of what
Christians today would say are the
Psalms like they're Psalms 23 that said
the Lord is my shepherd I shall not want
yeah and on and on and these were things
that you know we're carrying me
throughout my life at that point but
then again it was going back to the why
are you here is this enough do you feel
comfortable with what you're doing so
that's when it actually you know the
answer your question let into led me
into searching I mean I even looked at
rest rastafarianism for a while and then
you know Buddhism it's a it's a it's a
cool thing but at the end of the day I
was still left with the question are you
satisfied with the way you're living is
this something that when you go to bed
at night you would feel comfortable with
my soul just still wasn't satisfied with
all these isms so did you not find the
evidence you didn't find sufficient
proof that these were the truth and the
the for instance now in Buddhism or in
these other isms was there something
there that gave you a clear way how to
live your life from A to Z that wasn't
there what were you looking for that you
just didn't find fulfillment in these
other ways what what criteria was that
you were use headset well let's take
Buddhism for example this is a religion
that or a philosophy that says you know
you should be a very peaceful person
yeah you shouldn't even hurt the amp'd
it allows you to reflect for example my
favorite Buddhist quoting is one that
says the man
and whose are pulling the carrot pointed
the way with the carrot it really allows
a person to kind of take a step back and
look at life and give you a peaceful
view of life yeah so in terms of living
this life and being comfortable and
being peaceful in this life I think
Buddhism answers that question now the
bigger issue with for me Buddhism is
okay so what happens when you die who do
you answer to ah for me and for some
people Buddhism they found their answer
but for me I had the question why are
you here Buddhism really did didn't
answer that question for me I it it
showed me how to live my life how to get
through the day how to deal with chaos
within my life but I was still was not
satisfied at that point I still felt
that there is something or there is
someone some entity outside of myself
outside of this world that is moving
things that's causing things to move and
for me that wasn't answered now the way
of life the religion of your parents
believing that Jesus was one in three 3
& 1 the Trinity that he died he came as
a man he died and what about this talked
about this briefly well my that was
something that we thought that was one
of those one of the values the religious
values that as Christians we espoused um
I remember you know before I was
baptized we would quote acts 238 that
says no one comes about being baptized
in the name of Jesus the Father the Son
and the Holy Ghost and that was
something that led me to get baptized
but it at a point in my life I was still
faced with the question well if God is
Jesus and Jesus is God and God is a
spirit then how do you reconcile that
they were did that was always something
that you know and when I asked that
question it was given to me like well
think of an egg there is the shell
there's the yolk and then there's the
white it's still one egg but it's
it's three and one yeah I wasn't
satisfied with that there was also the
the answer of there's uh there's water
and ice and ice can become water and it
can become vapor think of that and I
said okay but something that kind of
pulled me towards Islam was when my
friend again his name is Vince he said
to me you know there's there's nothing
like God you can't compare anything to
him and that kind of jolted me towards
uh you know learning about Islam I still
thought it was a weird religion it was
something that you know people that sell
bean pies and people who visit the
pyramids are and men who dress in weird
clothes I still sought it as that
religion but when he mentioned to me
about you know this is your Creator and
he started reasoning with me which is
funny because I think at that point
Buddhism actually prepared me for Islam
in the sense because I my reasoning
ability i think was developed and
enhanced studying Buddhism but Islam
really forced you to think and to say
okay if you're here then there has to be
a reason why you're here and it's your
job it's your responsibility to find
that out so I think from an Islamic
perspective that kind of forced me to
rethink the whole thing that we call
life and I think at that point I think I
studied it's on for two years and it
just it i found slowly that questions
were being answered there were things
that at first I found a little bit this
is strange but then after I thought
about it and I reasoned with myself I
asked the right questions and I spoke to
the right people I had no choice if I
walked away from this thing called Islam
no matter how weird i think it is there
was something in my mind that said you
need to look at this take a second look
at this this is this is what you've been
looking for yeah so too much
till gymnastics going on trying to
figure out how God could be a man and
then be three and not three but one and
are all this other stuff it just didn't
make sense it didn't fit but you come
into Islam it answered all the questions
purpose of life the purpose of life is
clear it's prettier for me now the
perfect purpose of life is clear where
you're going when you die is it clear
it's clear who God is is that clear
that's clear tell us who is God well
that that's a that's a whole show in
itself I'm gonna briefly know that God
is nothing we can imagine the most
beautiful thing that our imagination
will allow us to and that's still not
God yeah as Muslims we're taught that
you cannot put God in a framework you
cannot put him in a box which is great
for the human being because he can then
aspire towards something greater because
if we think okay if we if we think as
human beings that we can enclose God in
a box then it's going to limit our
thinking our possibilities it's a it's
actually a disservice to ourselves but
as the Quran teaches us that God has
attributes and we could look around the
creation and see things that were forced
to ask ourselves then why is this here
how could this happen just at by chance
we know that when we go to bed at night
we were practically dead when we then we
come back we start up again we start a
new day yeah we look at the days we look
at the night we look at the the seasons
we look at the water we look at the the
earth that produces apples oranges
bananas plutonium all these things are
coming from one place and no human being
or no other thing but something
magnanimous would be able to create all
these things from one earth I mean the
Apple has a different taste it has a
different smell than the banana or the
orange but they're all coming from the
same place and through this scientific
process the Creator is is able to bring
these things forth and they nourish us
and what's even more fantastic is that
he brings us back into the earth yeah so
just looking at that one aspect of his
creation is enough as a proof for me
that there's something out there that is
in charge of all of this so Islam
clearly defines who the crater is and
this was something that just went down
easy not too much it's not mental asylum
narrator nothing complicated about a
complicated let's talk about before we
get into Islam and how this is a
benefited you and how it's changed your
life tell us uh we got you know any
something that's very convenient you
know you've been a young man and now you
have someone who because we acquire sins
through our life a week we make mistakes
but I wanted you got this idea this
story about someone who is carrying your
sins now how did you get away from and
was this embedded in you that someone
died for your sins and all you had to do
was believe this and you're okay that's
something that are and it's very easy I
mean it's if you really want to take the
easy way out hey all I have to do is
just believe and I'll be saved yeah but
in islam teaches you that you are given
you are given faculties which which you
must use as a person to save yourself or
to harm yourself each individual islam
really puts the responsibility on the
individual so if I go out and I do
something I can say okay I'll be saved
in reality life doesn't work like that
if I go out right now and I go kill
someone I have to suffer for it I have
to go to jail I have to go through a new
process and thus the state is going to
make sure that justice is done then why
is it that a Creator who is all-wise
would say okay do what you want and all
you have to do is believe the logic just
doesn't hold I can't say hey you know
what I'm going to do things and when I
do something I'm going to be saved
because i believe islam teaches you you
have to
leave but then you also have to have
something behind your belief that
solidifies that belief and what is that
that is action you have to you have to
do things and you have to believe so the
belief belief has two components it's in
your heart it's a and it's also actions
what you say and what you do I can't say
hey you know what I want Muslim and
that's it no I also i have to work I
have to do good works and the converse
is true you can't say you know what I
don't believe but I'm going to do good
things no the two go together you have
to believe it in your heart you have to
testify with it in your tongue and you
have to use your hands you have to use
your mind you have to use the faculties
which any person who has a brain or the
ability to think I think that would
resonate with the reasoning so there's
accountability and now you gotta prove
you're you love you got to prove here
your belief right actions exactly okay
that makes sense now topless now you
accept it up there's something off
telling us now that look we got to find
some words because we got a lot of
non-muslims they heard Islam they heard
Muslims and I know they might got some
other things in their head when we bring
up these words so we will just take a
second Islam simply means surrender
submission to the Creator alone him you
pray to Him you give charity for he is
the one that is dictating your life and
the Muslim is one who is doing Islam
Islam is a way of life that all the
prophets and messengers followed Wow
some and we can turn off the noise
interrupting us now you're a Muslim now
you've chosen you taking that free
choice the free world that you have now
to either go and worship a man to
worship account or should the Sun to
move maybe your desires now you could
have stopped it just made up your own
religion people they don't say they're
making up the religion but when they're
just doing their own thing making things
up so you know I'm just a good person is
in my heart and they'll just make things
up as they go along you knew that no
this is not you didn't even do we didn't
get into that but was there a point
before I go to my next point that maybe
you said that you know the heck with all
this I'm gonna just do my own thing did
you ever come to that at a point in my
life to be honest with you I felt that
you know what if I'm just a good person
and I take all the good
from the you know I kind of cherry pick
they are the best from Buddhism the best
from Judaism the best from Christianity
the best from Islam and I do a good
thing I should be okay yeah there was a
point when I I felt that that would be
okay why didn't you do that because
again in the back of my mind I just did
not feel there was something I cannot
tell you what it is but there was some
there was always the question of what is
this all about yeah are you being is
this are you being and I think you know
most people will say it's your
conscience but at some point your
conscience is going to tell you this is
not right or this is this is right and
even though in a limited sense that that
uh your conscience is not what you
follow but to a certain point it always
guides you and once you've reached the
point where you should be guided then
things kind of take over from that it
may not make sense but at some point
your conscience is always going to give
you an honest feedback so that was you
wouldn't be being honest and sincere
that just the easy way that's the easy
way out okay so let's go on to this now
now you're a Muslim now you've chosen to
do God's sting you chosen to do the cool
thing Islam is cool you want to do what
God wants you to do that's Islam simple
as that nothing less than paradise tell
us now what are some of that challenges
was it easy at first is it still is it
easy now do you feel like you got this
one way ticket you know it just all met
as they say hunky-dory or is just good
tell us now for those who have accepted
Islam because I personally witness it
that you know it's it's not something
that you know it's going to take some
work did it takes some work to start
praying five times a day that it takes
some work to leave off some of the
things that God tells you to leave off
and that's something that I think the
human being is a lazy and forgetful
person that's why mazie we have
commercials you know always reminding us
go by this or go by that and I think to
be honest with you when I first when I
was first introduced to Islam I was uh
you know I
and I love pork yeah that's an example I
I said you know what I can't give up the
pork yeah I can't give up infer I think
it may be a year I just said you know I
can't give up the pork it's a test now
and it was a test and I slowly but
surely I was able to i was able to
overcome that but they're things that we
all every person has a vice yeah and
even he could be the biggest [ __ ] or he
could be the the smallest evildoer yeah
he's he has a vice or she has a vice and
that's something that that that's a
challenge that is placed within the
human being whether he's a Muslim or
non-muslim a good person or a bad person
that if he or she is over it is able to
overcome that that vice or that thing
that can actually pull you one way or
the other then that person is beginning
the process of being true to him or
herself because you've recognized hey
I'm a weak person when it comes to this
I'm a weak person when it comes to that
but then once you're able to recognize
that and move beyond that and always
keep that in mind then I think the
process begins where you can be honest
with yourself you can be honest with
others and most importantly you can be
honest with your creative tell us what
are some of the proofs nowadays look you
know people when you bring up any kind
of ism they say okay this is just one of
those religions what distinguishes Islam
from the rest of these man-made
religions because I don't think we
should have to follow a man-made
religion a way of life that we follow
should be from the crater so how does
someone know that Islam is a way of life
from the Creator I think the
responsibility factor I mean you look at
the you look at the fact that as a
Muslim you're required to pray five
times a day mm-hmm no matter how much a
person the lees or disbelieve that's
going to be a test for him or her yeah
you're not just going to say you know
what I'm going to pray and I just go
through the motions if you're going to
spend a great portion of your day or a
significant times in your day when
you're praying
that should say something the other
thing is the fasting if you don't fast I
will never know you could or if I I can
say you know what we're fasting we're
all fasting and I go sneak and have
something to drink or I go do something
I'm not supposed to do during the
fasting so and come back and pretend
that I'm fasting but these are the
individual things that we do that
develops us that develop our our belief
system to believe that you know there is
a creator and he sees me no matter where
I go I can't escape my Creator so the
responsibility factor that ok I'm
responsibility for I'm responsible for
what i do and i will be asked about
everything that i do that really put
something in the human in the end of
mind that says you know at some point
you are going to be held accountable and
if we are honestly aware of that if
we're sincere to ourselves then I think
that's enough proof for us and there
were thousands of prophets that came and
their message was you know believe in
the one God and obey me but in order for
you to believe in order for you to obey
the Prophet you have to be responsible
you have to take responsibility for the
things that we do and the activities
that we engage in you think it's
someone's sincere he wants to know the
truth that it doesn't take too much too
many degrees to figure out that Islam is
the way that is from the crater does it
provide an ample amount of evidence that
someone just because it's easily we tend
to as human beings always look for the
easy way so I think that you know you
mentioned something before right now
this good point that you mentioned that
you know what the actions that Islam has
you do because a lot of the other ways
it's kind of like you just blend it in
with your life all right God says no no
no Allah the Creator that happens error
says no you put me first everything else
comes
second third for if you blend Islam in
right so now if someone's sincere
because some people like you mentioned
about the pork or maybe of alcohol
gambling you know what you know this
thing's by their action is more
important because they don't want to
give this up you were sincere enough you
gave this up for the crater you think
it's somewhat sincere and they use their
intellect what would be the first things
that they would have to do now to come
to where you are doing the cool thing
don't what God wants you to do Islam
well I don't want to you know profess to
be someone who was at a point where I'm
are perfected that this whole none of us
are far away from perfect ah but you
know we all have our struggles but I
think in order for someone to come to
that realization honesty you have to be
honest with yourself honesty yes I think
honesty it plays out yourself yes if
you're not honest with yourself then
it's going to create a lot of issues for
you and for those people who you come in
contact with your whole life is going to
be based on something other than honesty
so in order for someone to come to the
realization they have to be honest they
have to go out and seek knowledge and
use your intellect we were given an
intellect for a reason and in order for
us to you to to use that intellect to
its that its highest level we have to
have a certain degree of honesty because
if we're not honest we may see the truth
and we can even intellectualize away
from the truth because we are not being
honest with ourselves so be honest
couple more points that telling us we're
almost at a time is Islam something for
a certain race for the black people
because some people when you think of
Islam they think that this is a black
thing we're going to say but I mean I
have the same but like i said before
islam was just some weird religion for
it and some you know like for the Arabs
or for the blacks or you know people
selling bean pie and farah khan and no
Islam unfortunately Islam is a religion
that sees no colour it doesn't matter
who you are where you come from Islam
opens its door
so see the black and the white come on
gather worshiping longer Yeah right TV
so I mean we live in the United States
and this is a great country we've just
elected a black president in Islam this
would not be if this would not be
something great why because even when
there was slavery in the u.s. Islam was
saying no there's no difference between
the black or the white yeah there's no
difference between the man and the woman
so it's time is a radically as you would
say cool thing that as we go through
time and if we wish to be honest with
ourselves we go back and we look at was
what Islam has been presenting that
takes other entities or isms to figure
out as they evolve yeah Islam told us
that 1500 years ago 1400 years ago we
knew that having a black president it's
not a big deal why because in Islam
you're judged by your deeds and what you
believe and that the things you do not
buy your physic your physicality tell us
terrorism this might be on some of the
non-muslims mind they tuning in and
they're you know it's la Muslims and you
know right away they got this
stereotypes terrible you guys hear about
terrorism terrorism has no place in this
long no places ah as defined and people
always go through you know well there's
no need to apologize if someone is a
Muslim doesn't doesn't necessarily mean
that the person is it is not if someone
really is a Muslim he's not a terrorist
yeah because Muslims and this sounds
like a cliche but it's true Muslims
believe in justice we believe in peace
and as cliche as it may sound Islam is a
peaceful religion it's it's not a cliche
I challenge anyone out there to do any
research when Islam ruled Spain you had
Jews you had Muslims you had Christians
all living in the same society and you
can look at throughout the history of
Islam people say Islam was spread by the
sword that that is not true again I
challenge that that notion Islam has
always been a religion that promotes
peace when Islam ruled the world the
world was in peace what
Islam doesn't rule the world the world
is in pieces so terrorism has no place
in Islam no Muslim believes in
terrorizing other people or you know
killing innocent people for no reason
that is against Islam it's against
humanity it's against the basic belief
of life in regardless of your Muslim a
Christian and Jew into a Buddhist
whoever you are terrorism has no place
in those religion and in that in that
arena Islam is no different it's far
aslam and terrorism are not compatible
and with that notion of peace I'd like
to wish you peace assalamualaikum
thinking electrons in with us my brother
thank you for having me Thank You
Jessica Lahad I'd like to thank you for
tuning in to another episode of the Dean
show you got to hear it another mass
story of how he came to Islam Islam is
the cool thing calls you to think to
ponder why are you here are you here
just to play just have fun make a little
money and then you die think about it be
sincere like our guest said be honest
search for the truth ask the one who
created you and know where truth will
give you truth and will give you peace
and contentment in life and that's the
only way to live how the crater wants
you to live simple and that's Islam
doing Islam submitting your will to the
will of the create tour and we hope to
see you back here every week on the Dean
show we'll see you next time until then
Salaam alaikum peace be unto you it's
cold ain't lame everybody sleep in I
arise and ask a lot of thinking me Omar
you see hola you know all the sins I do
I turn to you to forgive my sin tomorrow
I missing for slave yo my learning Lord
I'm the one runs away oh the guide me